[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir lundi à 19 mars bienvenue pour
cette nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv soixante dix huit avec le
7-8 journal tout de suite les titres de
cette actualité de cette édition un
service pionnier en ile-de-france depuis
début janvier la communauté de communes
agali mode râlant ces flics 6 go c'est
un réseau de bus à la demande qui emmène
les voyageurs vers les gares et autres
arrêts du territoire un mode de
transport qui facilite les déplacements
en zone rurale 3000 restaurants sur les
cinq continents pour le plus grand dîner
français du monde goût de france 2018 se
tient mercredi et cette opération a pour
but de fêter la cuisine tricolore fait
de produits frais du terroir et dans les
yvelines le restaurant étoilé et gordon
ramsay participent à cet événement nous
recevrons son chef frédéric l'argument
enfin la 10e édition de l'eco trail de
paris étaient au programme ce dimanche
81 km au départ de lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines
une arrivée au premier étage de la tour
eiffel et 2500 participants ont dû
composer avec une météo compliquée et
puis autre invité de ce journal david
landaise représentants du groupe de
travail cantine bio à la sauce régale à
l'association qui propose une réunion
publique ce mercredi à guyancourt à
propos des cantines bio et local c'est à
suivre dans ce journal
elle s'est donc une première en ile de
france un service de bus à la demande il
a été mise en place depuis à début
janvier pour les habitants de la
communauté de communes a égalé mauldre
qui comprend notamment la ville est la
commune de saint nom la bretèche un
dispositif pour permettre de se déplacer
plus facilement aux zones rurales
reportage de camille lambert depuis
janvier de nouveaux véhicules ont fait
leur apparition dans la plaine de
versailles
un mode de transport d'un nouveau genre
un service de bus à la demande certains
le test pour la première fois j'ai testé
ce matin à 9h30
j'avais pris l'application il ya une
semaine comme ça j'avais déjeuné sur
paris donc les tester c'est assez
pratique
moi qui ai se remarie son mode en
général j'ai ma voiture là je prends pas
la voiture et j'ai voulu tester je
prends le taxi go séries c'est simple
flic sigourre mène les voyageurs de la
communauté de communes de gally mauldre
vers les gares ou les autres arrêts du
territoire pour réserver son trajet site
internet applications mobiles ou par
téléphone
un dispositif qui répond à un véritable
besoin pour cette zone rurale déjà 370
voyage ont été réalisés la première
préoccupation là le premier souhait la
première demande des habitants et des
usagers c'est effectivement d'avoir des
moyens de transport qu'ils soient
meilleurs que ce qui existait c'est
grâce effectivement aussi en
ile-de-france mobilité qui est le
nouveau nom du stif et à
donc à la région ile-de-france qui
maintenant véritablement est de la
grande couronne la région qui finance
aux deux tiers ce nouveau dispositif le
premier en ile de france
au total environ un million d'euros par
an sont investis pour cette expérience
un concept qui pourrait arriver dans
d'autres territoires la politique il
appelle à l'unité de la gauche benoît
hamon s'est exprimé dans une interview à
nos confrères du journal du dimanche
le fondateur du mouvement générations
cible particulièrement jean luc
mélenchon benoît hamon lui demanda lui
et son parti de la france insoumise
d'abandonner leur stratégie solitaire
l'ancien candidat à la présidentielle a
également indiqué qu'il sera dans la rue
ce jeudi pour la grève des cheminots et
des fonctionnaires et 1200 exposants et
3000 auteurs présents sur trois jours le
salon du livre s'est terminée
aujourd'hui à paris comme tous les ans
de nombreuses yvelinois étaient présents
notamment des maisons d'édition
indépendantes
une occasion rêvée pour rencontrer un
nouveau public et élargir leur réseau
nicolas landry et nicolas kirillovitch
se faire une place parmi les grands et
si possible se faire connaître au delà
des yvelines à côté des flammarion
grasset ou robert laffont au salon du
livre les maisons d'édition
indépendantes sont aussi présentes elles
sont un peu plus de 700 en ile de france
parmi elles inédit créé il ya 15 ans à
montigny le bretonneux et qui publie
tous les ans six ou sept romans en
échange avec les gens qui passent et qui
s'arrêtent devant nos livres
on peut leur parler de nos livres ils
parlent de leurs goûts de lecture etc
c'est aussi très intéressant d'un point
de vue professionnel pour échanger avec
les confrères on peut avoir une foule
qui vont se battre
pour ce faire signer votre nuage mais
c'est bien parce que bon
ça permet de rencontrer du monde aussi
ou de revoir des gens qu'on l'a pas vu
depuis très longtemps profité de la
notoriété du salon et de ses
opportunités c'est également l'ambition
des éditions versaillaise il adore à
quelques livres de la sa directrice
bénéficie elle aussi du stand mise à
disposition par la région ile-de-france
400 m² pour rencontrer un public
inhabituel porteur d'un autre regard se
rencontrent les publics qui dit ah ben
oui c'est que j'aime pas la couverture
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver en dés
seront p
on a l'occasion de parler donc
d'améliorer aussi notre travail en
moyenne chaque année les français
dépensent 116 euros dans leur budget
livres pour un chiffre d'affaires de
près de 4 milliards d'euros une manne
financière dont profitent largement
l'ile-de-france la région accapare elles
toutes seules un tiers de cette somme
150 pays à participants répartis sur
cinq continents la quatrième édition de
goût de france se tient ce mercredi
c'est au lendemain de la journée
internationale de la francophonie et
l'événement célèbre la cuisine française
à travers le monde 3000 restaurants
proposeront à des menus spécial pour
l'occasion dont le restaurant du trianon
palace à versailles bonsoir frédéric
l'art comme un bon soir vous êtes le
chef de ce restaurant le gordon ramsay
au trianon un restaurant étoilé donc de
cet hôtel versaillais quand on parle de
cuisine à la française
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire est ce
qu'on parle d'une cuisine d'exception
une cuisine reconnu à travers le monde
oui exactement une cuisine qui est très
reconnu dans le monde
cet événement était démarré avec presque
1500 chefs
cette année il ya 3 michel qui veulent y
participer l année prochaine ce sera
peut-être 4000 donc c'est l'importance
de la cuisine française dans le monde
on peut le voir comme ça un grand chef
d'ailleurs à l'origine de cet événement
c'est à alain ducasse exactement où
c'est un partenariat avec donc alain
ducasse qui a démarré goût de goût de
france avec le ministère des affaires
étrangères donc c'est une très bonne une
très bonne démarche et qui a beaucoup de
succès il est tout à fait normal pour
vous que cette cuisine française soit
célébrée à travers le monde je trouve
que oui c'est vrai qu'en de tout le
monde à ses cultures différentes dans le
monde entier au niveau de la gastronomie
la gastronomie française
elle était faite créé sur plusieurs
siècles
d'où l'importance de ce métier
maintenant on voit qu'il ya une
expertise vraiment au niveau des
produits de nos producteurs des éleveurs
le respect du produit
toutes les sauces ou s'ils sont vraiment
des c'est une histoire qui est très très
riche
et voilà donc maintenant c'est vrai que
ça déteint beaucoup sur sur le monde
entier c'est ce n'est que du bon pour
nous est-ce que aussi toute la cuisine
française à sa place selon vous on voit
plusieurs établissements participent à
ces événements de la haute gastronomie
comme c'est le cas au gordon ramsay au
trianon jusqu'à la cuisine française de
bistrot elle a toute sa place aux essais
cette cuisine française complètement
il faut bien manger partout il en faut
pour tous les goûts pour tous les
portefeuilles aussi donc c'est
le but c'est de faire bon c'est pas
parce qu'on paye plus cher que c'est
meilleur
donc voilà ça c'est important la cuisine
française on peut la manger partout et
en toutes les gammes de restaurants
alors un goût de france 2018 forcément
amer quelques semaines après la
disparition de paul bocuse quel héritage
at il laissé selon vous avec le visage
énorme d'une de pouvoir lancer goût de
goût de france et des hommes des hommes
comme monsieur comme monsieur paul
justement qu'on pu nous pousser à faire
justement un événement comme ça le
rendent hommage cette année c'est
vraiment une
une belle une belle preuve de respect
qu'on peut avoir pour pour lui tout le
monde l'a croisé en moins une fois et
cette fois ci on va tous le remercier
sur une de ses spécialités dans nos
menus
ça sera donc au programme de ces
programmes on aura deux de petites
on aura deux plats qui vont
qu'ils sortent justement des cuisines de
paul bocuse on va avoir l'occasion
justement de parler de ce menu que vous
proposerez déjà pour les téléspectateurs
qui ne vous connaissent pas le style
frédéric l'argument c'est quoi ce titre
frédéric largement moins déjà c'est une
cuisine gourmandise de ma jeunesse on
cuisine de mai de mes parents de mes
grands parents
de mon parcours aussi parce que j'ai
aussi pas mal voyagé et c'est l'émotion
que j'ai eues en apprenant derrière de
grands chefs
maintenant c'est une émotion que je veux
mettre dans ma cuisine pour que les
clients puissent faire ressentir aussi
alors vous le dites vous avez côtoyé de
grands chefs vous avez été formé à
l'école grégoire ferrandi vous avez
travaillé aux côtés des chefs
henri charvet michel bourdin gordon
ramsay alain ducasse comment vous êtes
tombé dans la cuisine quai d'où vous
vient cette passion de la cuisine
voilà la gourmandise 16h50 déjà de
toujours bien manger c'est vrai que j'ai
eu une éducation ou c'étaient des heures
des heures précises à table des toujours
entrée plat fromage dessert toujours en
famille s'était pas c'était pas une
cantine donc il fallait vraiment manger
en famille et après le goût des bonnes
choses le goût du terroir et puis aussi
de commencer à toucher à d'autres
cocotte et et ensuite se lancer voilà
dans le métier c'était un plaisir
alors depuis novembre 2007 êtres le chef
exécutif du gordon ramsay au trianon
la recette du succès c'est c'est quoi
c'est la rigueur avant tout rigueur
patience passion et voilà c'est un long
marathon qu'elle il faut il faut
s'accrocher mais c'est un très beau
métier et travailler dans au trianon
palace on le sait dans le cadre du parc
du château de versailles dans le cadre
d'un long de l'histoire française est ce
que c'est des conditions exceptionnelles
pour re pour exercer les cloisonnements
complètement on a je pense qu'une des
cuisines les plus
confortable de la région parisienne nous
avons la même vu que nos clients sur sur
les jardins du château de versailles
c'est un le trianon palace offre des
terrasses incroyable en belle saison
donc c'est très demandé les gens sont
pas vraiment de bons moments le
restaurant la véranda nous avons donc le
restaurant gordon ramsay au trianon marc
galerie donc c'est vrai que l'on a tout
pour passer un bon moment donc
dernière chose le menu forcément va
terminer en mettant l'eau à la bouche à
nos téléspectateurs à quel menu vous
allez concocté pour cet événement goût
de france on va commencer par donc pour
rendre hommage monsieur bocuse un gratin
de d'écrevisses pardon faire façon
fernand point qui était son mentor dans
les années 50
nous allons voir
ris de veau pour commencer on aura des
saint jacques après on aura une volaille
de chez tauzin façon albufeira on va
avoir un vieux compte est aussi hors
d'âge
exceptionnel et puis hein
somptueux vacherin aussi fait par notre
chef à 6 et eddie benghanem et pour plus
d'informations sur cet événement goût de
france 2010 du tout sûr également le
restaurant gordon ramsay au trianon vous
pouvez vous rendre sur les deux sites
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
avant de vous laisser partir frédéric
l'art que moins on parle dans un instant
et que un autre invité d'une réunion
publique ce mercredi à guyancourt pour
des cantines bio et local à guyancourt
proposer des produits bio locaux vous en
tant que chef est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui peut vous toucher
est ce que c'est une initiative
intéressante c'est très important autant
pour nous les restaurateurs les écoles
je pense que c'est le premier
établissement qui doivent bien manger
parce que c'est les enfants de tout le
monde
donc si on peut mettre en avant les
produits bio locaux
c'est ça veut c'est bien pour les
enfants et c'est bien aussi pour nos
producteurs ont résolu merci à frédéric
l'arc commun d'avoir été avec nos chefs
exécutifs du gordon ramsay au trianon et
le bio et le local c'est dans un instant
sur tv 78 alors juste avant le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera dans dix jours en piste pour
l'emploi pendant 12 heures les
participants vont pouvoir rencontrer des
employeurs mais aussi échanger avec des
entreprises ont encore à s'informer sur
les différents organismes de formation
une conférence de presse avait lieu ce
midi au ski cube à guyancourt ori nir
ont été sur place 200 entreprises et
près de 2000 offres d'emploi voici ce
qui vous attend le 29 mars prochain
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
en piste pour l'emploi proposera
plusieurs espaces dédiés au recrutement
et à la formation
un événement qui se veut novateur c'est
un moment très pédagogique pour pour un
demandeur d'emploi
mais en même temps très activateur
puisque il est directement en rapport
avec près de 200 entreprises qui sont à
sa disposition toute une journée pendant
12 heures avec un taux de chômage de 7,2
pour cent au dernier trimestre 2010 est
le département des yvelines affiche une
situation plutôt favorable par rapport
au reste de la france
néanmoins la part des demandeurs
d'emploi inscrits depuis plus de deux
ans continue à augmenter
première observateurs de cette tendance
pôle emploi qui sera présent lors de
l'événement
nous avons d'ailleurs des conseillers
pôle emploi qui animeront tout au long
de la journée nous aurons également des
conseillers pôle emploi qui vont
accompagner leurs demandeurs d'emploi
notamment parmi les porteurs de
l'accompagnement intensive jeunes et qui
viendront effectivement accompagner les
publics tout au long de cette journée
vraiment enrichissante
le numérique tiendra également une place
importante lors de ce rendez-vous
information animation mais aussi job
dating attendent les futurs participants
qui s'inscrivent ils regardent et
l'intérêt c'est que les
les chefs d'entreprise vont regarder les
cv donc il ya déjà après une
présélection qui sera faite par rapport
à un certain nombre de critères ça c'est
important
et puis
il ya également les gens qui veulent
venir en 160 inscriptions objectif pour
saint quentin en yvelines que chacun
puisse trouver le 29 mars un emploi
durable
un nouvel invité marc a rejoint en
plateau david landaise bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes membre de la sauce régal vous
êtes le représentant du groupe de
travail cantine bio au sein de cette
association également parents d'élèves
guyancourt toile heures ce mercredi
vous proposez une réunion publique des
cantines bio et local à vue en cours
c'est possible c'est le titre de cette
réunion publique c'est à 20h30
déjà avant de parler de cette réunion
publique un mot peut-être sur
l'association la sauce se régaler
l'oeuvre pour une agriculture saine et
durable voilà l'association régal est
une association ayant courtoise plutôt
jeunes ça fait deux ans qu'elle existe
et est organisé selon divers pôles
notamment des parties visibles qui sont
les six groupes de circuits courts comme
une amap
il nous fournit des légumes chaque
semaine avec un arrêt chez qui
travaillent sur magny les hameaux et une
épicerie participative qui est aussi
implanté sur le quartier du pont du
rotois qui permet au plus grand nombre
de bénéficier de produits sains bio ou
locaux ou évidemment les deux une autre
partie de l'association est organisé un
groupe de travail notamment un les
cantines bio qui m'intéresse plus
particulièrement et d'autres groupes qui
sont par exemple travaillé sur l'homme
la préservation des terres agricoles qui
existent encore sur un circuit en cours
plusieurs plusieurs
thématiques au sein de cette association
alors cette réunion publique de mercredi
elle se fait dans le cadre d'une
campagne qui est menée par la sauce
régal qui s'appelle relocalisons du en
cours c'est quoi cette campagne et quels
sont les objectifs d'une telle campagne
relocalisons but en cours alors c'est
notre deuxième campagne la gagnante a
travaillé sur l'autonomie alimentaire
notamment par la map est parent par
l'épicerie qui a nous a menés à recensé
environ 200 familles qui travaillaient
leur autonomie alimentaire sortir un
petit peu de la grande distribution et
se réapproprier la façon de s'alimenter
en continuant euros sur la
relocalisation de guyancourt sur toutes
les initiatives qui peuvent nous
permettre de diminuer notre empreinte
écologique sur notre environnement et au
mieux son travail en direct lors ce
chiffre 86% des français sont favorables
à l'introduction d'aliments bio et
locaux dans la restauration collective
publique alors c'est d'après un dernier
sondage ifop
pourquoi à votre avis accordons plus
d'importance aujourd'hui à ces
thématiques le bio le local pourquoi
c'est devenu important ces dernières
années selon alors on s'est dit beaucoup
d'études sont sortis sur un l'impact des
pesticides sur notre santé dans
l'agriculture conventionnelle
on retrouve très régulièrement des
réseaux de pesticides donc souvent à
faible dose mais qui sont considérés
aussi comme perturbateur endocrinien et
qui peuvent avoir des impacts sur notre
santé à long terme
donc pour nous tous qui peut diminuer
cet impact et est important notamment
sur les enfants qui sont une population
fragile en tant que papa de deux enfants
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à coeur
de leur fournir une alimentation saine
et notamment aussi par le biais de la
des cantines scolaires
et pourtant au delà de d'action comme
la sauce régal d'action d'associations
comme la sauce régal on a l'impression
que les choses avancent pas encore assez
vite
comment il explique aussi que les les
collectivités peut-être
n'aillent pas plus vite sur le sujet du
bio et du local souvent ce qui est mis
en avant c'est le coup du bio
effectivement un produit bio et coûte
plus cher qu'en de produits
conventionnels pour plusieurs raisons sa
vue qu'on n'utilise pas de produits
insecticides ou de produits herbicides
chimiques l'impact de l'homme sur la
culture est beaucoup plus important et
nécessite plus de main d'oeuvre
ça c'est une dépense est ce qu'on peut
entendre sur le bio le fait que ça coûte
plus cher que l'agriculture plus
traditionnels ça c'est s'aider des
poncifs qui vont être déconstruit
notamment à cette réunion publique
mercredi
voilà on ne peut pas considérer le juste
le prix du produit en lui-même il faut
savoir que si on aura pas de cantine
scolaire
on peut le coût des matières premières
ce qui nous intéresse c'est 15 à 20 % du
coût total du repas donc quand on parle
d'un produit d'un repas plus cher ça va
être de l'ordre du dix vingt trente
centimes plus cher et il existe de
nombreux moyens de réduire l'impact de
ceux de ce surcoût a notamment par un
travail sur le gaspillage alimentaire
qui est très important globalement et en
créant cantines scolaires faut savoir
que pour par exemple pour une cantine en
école primaire en moyenne en france 70
grammes de nourriture sont jetés à
chaque repas et c'est une proportion qui
augmente même vers l'est en lice et qui
arrivait jusqu'à 150 g de gaspiller par
repas rien qu'en travaillant sur ce
surcoût il ya des communes je pense
notamment la commune ii - surtout dans
le sud est de la france
car en travaillant sur le gaspillage
alimentaire a réussi à absorber
complètement et même à réduire le coût
de son repas concrètement aujourd'hui
mettre du bio du local dans les
assiettes des élèves qu'est ce que ça
changerait concrètement vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la réduction de
l'empreinte qu'on peut avoir sur sur
cette planète c'est l'une des pistes qui
qui peuvent changer mais qui peuvent
changer les choses de mettre le vieux
local dans les assiettes
c'est une chose qui peut absolument
avoir un gros impact
un gros impact
[Musique]
7en
excusez moi y'a pas de soucis le oui
qu'est ce que ça changerait concrètement
selon vous de mettre du bio
la diminution de l'empreinte oui vous en
disiez embellisseur de de l'empreinte
écologique écologie elle à la diminution
de l'influencé des perturbateurs
endocriniens et des pesticides sur sur
nos enfants voilà la préservation de la
santé par l'alimentation l'éducation
unanime à un alimentation différente
comme moyen de réduction du du coût du
repas on a parlé du on a parlé du
gaspillage alimentaire
on peut aussi travailler sur par exemple
sur la diminution des protéines animales
des portions de viande qui peuvent être
remplacés par des parts des protéines
végétales
c'est aussi une piste importante de
réduction du coût du repas
c'est vraiment un travail un travail
global et qui demandent de prendre le
problème vient notamment de travail avec
les producteurs locaux
oui qui sont en coopérative un
groupement vraiment savoir quels sont
les produits qui peuvent être
disponibles localement pour être intégré
dans nos noms dans une cantine scolaire
dernière chose on l'a dit vous êtes
représentant donc du groupe de travail
cantine bio pour la sauce régal ce
travail actuellement il en il en est où
est ce qu'il ya des discussions avec les
élus billancourt toit notamment où en
est ce travail aujourd'hui
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas commencé
notre discussion avec les élus pour
l'instant ce qu'on cherche à faire c'est
mobiliser les parents d'élèves
l'accord massivement pour vérifier que
l'intérêt sur ce sujet est là et bien là
donc on commence par cette réunion
mercredi on compte ensuite organisé une
pétition à destination des élus de
guyancourt on se fixe un objectif
d'atteindre 500 signatures de parents
sur cette pétition pour pouvoir montrer
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
intéresse tous les parents d'élèves et
pas seulement notre association et on va
continuer la sensibilisation des parents
par la projection d'un film que nous
espérons faire au mois de juin
zéro phyto 100% bio qui peut qui ne
présentent que nos banques notamment des
beaucoup d'initiatives de communes sur
un tour de vis du bio dans les cantines
et une fois qu'on aura fait tout ça on
espère pouvoir mettre tout le monde
autour d'une table pour discuter ce
qu'on peut faire réellement guyancourt
merci david mendes d'avoir été avec nous
membres de la sauce régal et vous êtes
donc représentants du groupe de travail
cantine bio au sein de cet assaut
sanglant pour plus d'informations rendez
vous sur le site internet qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran
le sport c'est l'une des courses les
plus compliquées a terminé en
ile-de-france l'eco trail de paris s'est
élancé ce samedi est depuis à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines au
programme 80 km sur des sentiers verts
en passant par guyancourt but heavily et
vélizy le final au premier étage de la
tour eiffel michael et demi d'euros et
nicolas nourrissent un record de
participants pour cette et cauterets
2018 ils étaient plus de 2500 courageux
à s'être inscrits au départ du 80 km
depuis l'île de loisirs de saint quentin
en yvelines
objectif rejoint le premier étage de la
tour eiffel c'est sympa assez une bonne
ambiance
j'irais pas jusqu'a dire qu'on est entre
locaux mais c'est le plus collectif des
sports individuels que je connais ont
fait un bout de route avec quelqu'un on
le lâche sans recours avec quelqu'un
d'autre c'est sympa comme tous les
participants qui ont dû faire face à des
températures glaciales proche des 0
degré pour combattre ces conditions
climatiques chaque trailer à cette
technique augmente à la casbah bon petit
coup de vent et puis ben se réchauffer
entre entre coureurs entre coureurs de
froid le froid et du coup l'alimentation
aussi s'alimenter et s'hydrater
régulièrement pour ne pas avoir une
mousse sur la fin autre difficulté un
terrain très gras dès les premiers
mètres sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
en effet des zones qui sont assez
inondées justement avec beaucoup de
flaques d'eau et là ça va être un peu
compliqué sur certains passages des
conditions compliquées qui n'ont pas
refroidi le vainqueur de l'épreuve
emmanuel meyssat tu ce sportif de
l'extrême a bouclé les 80 km en 6 heures
et 59 secondes
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
nouvelle édition c'est la première étape
de ce chantier de restauration la
chapelle royale du château de versailles
s'offre un lifting et ce lundi matin
trois statuts de la toiture l'édifice
ont été enlevés à l'aide d'une grue de
70 mètres de haut une opération pour
permettre la remise en état de cet
ensemble les détails de nicolas dans
brice la statue d'un angelot dans le
ciel hivernal de versailles une
sculpture déplacés du sommet de la
chapelle royale du château une opération
à l'aide d'une grue de 70 mètres de haut
dans le cadre de la restauration de ce
bâtiment historique
un chantier lancé il ya un peu plus de
six mois c'est un moment très émouvant
parce que c'est d'abord très délicat
comme opérations et puis ces groupes
vont partir en restauration
pour le reste tout ce qui reste sur
place qui va être traité c'est la
maçonnerie la pierre de taille les
sculptures les vitraux les vitraux vont
être déposés également les ossatures
métalliques la charpente et la
couverture
au total trois statues ont été descendus
elles forment la sculpture appelée trois
enfants autour d'un palmier une oeuvre
de guillaume coustous et pierre le
poteau réalisé au début du xviiie siècle
qui va connaître un lifting d'un an dans
un atelier une restauration de temps
premièrement restauration des armatures
internes justement avait remplacement de
ces armatures trop altérés puisqu'on est
en présence de statut en plomb qui sont
creuses dons pour pouvoir les maintenir
en place il faut qu'ils aient des
structures internes métalliques dont
nous avons restauré ses structures
internes ou les remplacer le cacher on
est ensuite restauration de l'épiderme
du plomb le chantier de la chapelle
royale ne fait que commencer
coût global de cette restauration 16
millions d'euros financé par des mécènes
les travaux devraient être finalisées
d'ici trois ans ce week-end c'était la
saint patrick l'occasion pour faire la
fête comme à elancourt vous allez le
voir sur ces images le club et des chocs
ce organiser un disco roller 13
irlandais donc beaucoup de personnes
avait respecté le thème du verre une
soirée pour patiner en musique et des
animations course et danses étaient
également proposés je vous propose
d'écouter justement ces réactions au
micro de nicolas d'andrus il n'y a pas
beaucoup de d'animation de ce type de
choses de ce type
e
autour pour les gens qui veulent patine
et surtout à cette période de l'année
est donc ça permet aux gens de venir
patiner dans un endroit qui est fermée
qui est sécurisé c'est familial ça ça
permet à tout le monde de se retrouver
de ces sympathiques
j'ai des origines bretonnes donc toutes
les traditions celtes et autres j'aime
bien donc la saint-patrick baas et tous
les angles ses billets et puis avant de
se quitter l'alerté orange neige verglas
levée dans les yvelines depuis 10h ce
matin et pas de neige attendues pour le
reste de la semaine les températures
seront tout de même fraîche demain mardi
pour le premier jour du printemps c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal merci de
l'avoir suivi retrouvez nous également
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile tv 60,18 belle soirée
à tous
[Musique]